[موسيقى]
نعلم أنها بيثاني خارج الأردن
على الضفة الشرقية لنهر الأردن ،
هذا هو المكان المحدد الذي
يعتقد المسيحيون فيه أن المسيح قد تعمد.
لقد جئت إلى هنا للقاء
الوصي والزعيم السياسي الإقليمي
الملك عبد الله الثاني ملك الأردن.
نختتم عام 2022 ، نحن هنا
لمناقشة التحديات التي تواجه هذه
المنطقة ، ليس أقلها مخاوفه بشأن
تقلص عدد السكان المسيحيين في المنطقة
ولماذا يعتقد أن خطط تطوير
وحماية هذا الموقع المقدس أمر بالغ الأهمية
لمستقبل المجتمع في الشرق
الأوسط
[موسيقى]
من دواعي سروري المطلق أن تكون لديكم ، أريد أن
أتحدث عن سبب وجودنا هنا
وأهمية هذا الموقع ولكني أريد
أن أبدأ بخطابك في Unga
هذا العام لأنني أعتقد أنه
وثيق الصلة بما
سنناقشه معكم.  عنوانك بالقول إن
هناك أجراس إنذار أزمات عديدة تعمل على
تحسين
عالمنا أزمات متداخلة بشكل متزايد
صراعات إقليمية ذات تأثير دولي
اليوم مستقبل القدس
هو مصدر قلق عاجل
أن المدينة مقدسة لمليارات المسلمين
والمسيحيين واليهود في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
مما يؤدي إلى تقويض الوضع القانوني
والتاريخي للقدس الحالي ، مما
يؤدي إلى توترات عالمية
وتعميق الانقسامات الدينية
،
يجب ألا تكون المدينة المقدسة مكانًا للكراهية والانقسام ،
يمكنك فقط التفكير
في عام 2022  . لقد اعتقدنا دائمًا أن القدس
هي مدينة يجب أن تجمعنا جميعًا ،
ولكن للأسف
يستخدمها المتطرفون من جميع الأطراف لخلق
الصراع والعنف ، وقد بدأ
العنف بالفعل في
الربيع ، فنحن أوصياء على كليهما.
المواقع المنزلية المسيحية والإسلامية في
القدس ، ما يقلقني هو أن هناك
تحديات تواجه الكنائس
من السياسات على الأرض إذا
واصلنا استخدام القدس
كنقطة انطلاق للسياسة ،
فيمكن أن تخرج الأمور عن نطاق السيطرة
بسرعة حقًا وصفت
المسيحية  في القدس تحت النار ،
هل يمكنك أن تشرح قليلاً
أننا محظوظون في هذا البلد
وفي القدس  أقدم
مجتمع مسيحي عربي في العالم
كانوا هنا منذ 2000 عام على
مدار السنوات العديدة الماضية ، ونرى
أنهم أصبحوا تحت الضغط
كمجتمع ، لذا فإن الأرقام تتناقص
وهو ما أعتقد أنه جرس إنذار لجميع
لقد تبين أن عام 2022 هو العام الأكثر دموية
بالنسبة للصراع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني
منذ عقدين من الزمن ، وتعد القدس
نقطة اشتعال رئيسية ،
وهناك مخاوف من إجراء مقابلة
ثالثة في الأفق.
الأب السابق
وإذا حدث ذلك فهذا
انهيار كامل للقانون والنظام ولن يستفيد منه
أي من الإسرائيليين أو
الفلسطينيين
وأعتقد أن هناك الكثير من القلق
من جانبنا جميعًا في المنطقة بما في ذلك أولئك الموجودون في
إسرائيل  الذين يقفون إلى جانبنا بشأن هذه
المشكلة للتأكد من عدم حدوث
ذلك ، فهذه وميض أو Tinderbox
إذا كان وميض شيء
لا أعتقد أننا سنكون قادرين على الابتعاد
عنه في
وصف المعلق الأردني في المستقبل القريب هذه
النتيجة بأنها أسوأ كابوس للأردن هو أنه
في نهاية اليوم
يحق للشعب الإسرائيلي اختيار من
يريد قيادته وأعتقد أننا جميعًا
أولاد كبار هنا أمم تنظر إلى
الصورة الأكبر نحن جميعًا على استعداد
للمضي قدمًا ، لذا سنعمل مع أي شخص ومع
الجميع
طالما أننا نستطيع أن نجمع الناس
معًا
، فمن المرجح
أن تكون الحكومة الإسرائيلية الجديدة هي الجناح اليميني في
تاريخ إسرائيل بما في ذلك
مستشار الأمن القومي القادم ، بنغافير.
تاريخ من التحريض على العنف ضد
العرب والفلسطينيين
بانتظار تشريع جديد يمكنه أن يتولى
السلطة على قوة الشرطة
بما في ذلك محادثة إنفاذ القانون
الأماكن المقدسة في القدس
كوصي على تلك المواقع ، هل
تعتقد أن الوضع الراهن ودورك مهدد
لذلك ستحصل دائمًا على  هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين سيحاولون دفع
ذلك وهذا مصدر قلق لكنني لا أعتقد أن
هؤلاء الأفراد تحت
المجهر الأردني فقط  هم تحت
مجهر دولي حتى تعلم
أننا تعلمنا ذلك كما نقول دائمًا
العيش بين العراق ومكان صعب
تعلمون أن هذا مجرد
يوم ثلاثاء آخر بالنسبة لنا إذا أراد الناس الدخول
في صراع معنا  نحن
جاهزون تمامًا ، أود دائمًا أن أصدق أنه
دعونا ننظر إلى نصف الجدار الزجاجي ولكن
لدينا بعض الخطوط الحمراء وإذا
أراد الناس دفع تلك الخطوط الحمراء ،
فسنتعامل مع ذلك ولكن علي أن
أصدق أن هناك الكثير من الأشخاص  في
إسرائيل أيضًا التي نشعر بالقلق بقدر
ما نحن ، وكقائد مسلم ،
دعني أقول بوضوح
إننا ملتزمون بالدفاع عن
حقوق التراث الثمين
والهوية التاريخية
للشعب المسيحي في منطقتنا ، يمكنك
فقط توسيع دور الأردن في
إن تعزيز الاستقرار كان الأردن
ملجأ للمسيحيين الأوائل ويسوع
المسيح نفسه الذي أتى إلى هنا
هربًا من الاضطهاد ، أعتقد
أن هذا شيء ورثناه دائمًا
وقد قال جدي الأكبر
قدسي.  لمسيحيينا الأرمن
الذين كانوا يبحثون عن
الأمان والأمن ومؤخراً خلال السنوات
القليلة الماضية كما
شاهدتم أعمال داعش في سوريا والعراق لرعاية
المسيحيين العراقيين وأه والمسيحيين السوريين
هنا إذا لم يكن لدينا أي
مسيحيين  في المنطقة ، أعتقد أن
هذه كارثة بالنسبة لنا جميعًا ، فهم جزء من
ماضينا ، فهم جزء من حاضرنا
ويجب أن يكونوا جزءًا من مستقبلنا
[موسيقى] ،
يرجى اللعنات حيث تعمد يسوع المسيح
في المسيحية التي
أتوا منها  في جميع أنحاء العالم كل عام
يتدفق ما يصل إلى 200000 حاج وسائح إلى هذا الموقع حيث
يُعتقد أن يسوع قد تعمد الآن
تم إطلاق خطة رئيسية لبناء
قرية حاج بها متحف
مدرج وأماكن إقامة
وفقًا للجنة موقع المعمودية
سيسمح لها بتلبية ما يصل إلى
مليون ونصف زائر سنويًا
هو المدير العام للجنة موقع المعمودية
وهدفها الأساسي هو
بناء
مرافق مثل accomm
متاحف odation كل ما يحتاجه الحجاج
أساسًا
والهدف الرئيسي هو استقبال
ملايين الحجاج وتقديم خدمات أفضل
للاستمتاع بزيارتهم
للموقع
لديك خطط لتطوير وحماية
هذا الموقع أو الموقع المجاور لمكان
وجودنا كما نتحدث.  تماشياً مع
دورك تجاه الأماكن المقدسة الواقعة تحت
الوصاية الهاشمية ، تحدث معي عن
هذه الخطط ، لذلك هذا موقع تراث لليونسكو
ويحتاج إلى الحماية ،
نريد التأكد من الحفاظ عليه
لعدة قرون قادمة ، ما سيحدث
بجواره هو  ما هو
الدعم لهذا المكان السحري التاريخي الرائع
حتى تعرف متحفًا للحديث
عن تاريخ المسيحية ولإلقاء
نظرة على إنشاء حدائق نباتية
تزرع الزهور والأعشاب القديمة
في المنطقة ومراكز تدريب النباتات
التي تسمح للكنائس المختلفة  تعال
وعلم شيئًا يمكننا جميعًا أن
نفخر به بعد 100 عام من الآن وأعتقد أن
أحد الأشياء التي
يسيء الناس فهمها  هذه المساحة هي مدى
شمول ما
يقرب من 15 في المائة من الزوار
الذين يأتون إلى هنا من المسلمين لأننا
نبجل يسوع المسيح باعتباره المسيح
وأن مريم القديسة هي
أقدس وأهم جميع النساء في
تاريخنا وهكذا هذا  هي فرصة
لكسر تلك الحواجز
وإظهار مدى فخرنا ليس فقط أهنا
تاريخي أهنا مسيحي أه تراث أه هنا
في الأردن ولكن العلاقة بين
المسيحية والإسلام
مهمة هذا الموقع للأردن من
وجهة نظر دينية تاريخية أنت
تعرف أن هذا هو ثالث موقع مقدس للمسيحية المسيحية ، لذا فهو ذو
أهمية
قصوى للأردن وبسبب التاريخ فإنه
لا يخبرنا فقط عن واحد من أوائل
اللاجئين كونه يسوع الذي جعله
سفراء السلام ولكنك تعرف موجات اللاجئين التي
على الأقل في  الوقت الذي
رأيناه فيه أعتقد أنه بدأ هنا
وهي قصة تحكي قصة
الأردن على مر العصور
منذ عقود كان الأردن ملاذاً
آمناً لشري  يمثل المسلمون والمسلمون على حد
سواء نموذجًا للتعايش
وسط الجزء الأفضل من التاريخ ، حيث لا توجد
منطقة مضطربة في
أي مكان أكثر وضوحًا من
وسط مدينة عمان خلال احتفالات عيد الميلاد
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا لك
المجد لـ Victory
[الموسيقى]
هذا المشروع
سيبدأ في  آمال عام 2023. ما هي
آمالك ، فلنختتم هذا
بملاحظة إيجابية ، ما هي آمالك
وتطلعاتك لعام 2023 في نهاية
اليوم ، يريد الناس فقط المضي قدمًا في
حياتهم ويشعرون بفرصة ،
لذلك كيف نكتب  السرد
بقدر ما كان تحديًا مثل عام 2022
وصعبًا مثل مخاطر عام 2023 ،
هناك فرصة لنا للتحرك إلى
ما بعد ، وقد ابتعدت عن
الشعور بأن السياسة لن
تحل مشاكلنا ، إنها التبعية الاقتصادية ،
لذا فهذه هي  القضايا التي
يتعين علينا التعامل معها الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
الأردنيين وأعتقد
أن التكامل الإقليمي سيكون وأعتقد
أن سر قدرتنا على
كسر الحواجز  عندما أستثمر في
نجاحك لأن نجاحك هو
نجاحي في نهاية اليوم يعني أنه
يمكننا المضي قدمًا في أي شيء
يفكر فيه الناس حول اندماج إسرائيل
في المنطقة وهو أمر مهم
للغاية لن يحدث ما لم يكن
هناك مستقبل  الفلسطينيون
وقد رأيتم ذلك مؤخرًا من خلال
فريق كرة القدم المغربي
وهذا مجرد نوع من البصيرة الطفيفة
التي في نهاية المطاف ، مهما كان ما
يفعله القادة إذا لم نتمكن من حل هذه
المشكلة ، فإن الشارع
سيكون بطبيعة الحال.  متعاطفين مع
القضية الفلسطينية لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى البناء
بدلاً من
تدمير امم السوبر شكرا
جزيلا لك شكرا جزيلا لك
أجنبي